hey everyone did you know that the
global cloud computing Market is
projected to reach over 1 trillion
dollar by 2024 cloud computing has
become an essential tool for businesses
and organizations worldwide allowing
them to store managed process data more
efficiently where do you begin according
to a recent survey by right scale the
top three Cloud platforms are AWS Azure
and Google Cloud platform learning cloud
computing can be a challenging task but
it is a valuable skill to have in
today's digital era so before you start
exploring these platforms you need to
have a solid foundation in the
fundamentals of cloud computing and to
do so here we are with this informative
video to discuss the path to become a
cloud expert first is to understand the
fundamentals of cloud computing the
cloud computing fundamental course by
skill up is an excellent resource for
beginners it covers the basics of cloud
computing such as the types of clouds
cloud service models and deployment
models this course will provide you with
a solid foundation and prepare you for
more advanced topics to know for more
details check the link in the
description second is choose a cloud
platform once you have a basic
understanding of cloud computing the
next step is to focus on a specific
Cloud platform AWS Microsoft Azure and
gcp are the top three Cloud platforms
suppose you decide to pursue AWS one of
the most popular Cloud platforms
available in that case the AWS certified
Solutions architect course is an
excellent option irrespective of your
choice of platform we have courses on
all three to get you started links are
in the description below then comes
Advanced cloud computing skills after
mastering the fundamentals of cloud
computing and gaining Proficiency in a
specific Cloud platform the next step is
to develop your cloud computing skills
further the cloud computing skill up
course is an excellent resource for
professionals who want to advance their
careers in the cloud computing industry
this this course covers a wide range of
topics including Cloud architecture
security data storage and machine
learning to know more check out the link
in the description and the final step is
to practice and gain certification
practicing what you have learned and
obtaining certification is crucial in
the cloud computing industry AWS
Microsoft Azure and gcp also various
certification programs that validate
your knowledge and expertise in cloud
computing obtaining certification can
significantly improve your chances of
learning a job or advancing your career
in the cloud computing industry however
learning cloud computing can be a
daunting task fortunately simply learn
offers a fully fletchered cloud
computing skill-up course that can help
you develop your cloud computing skills
further
do you know the best part well this
course is completely free and you can
also access its lecture anytime in a 90
days pack quite easy right
well in conclusion learning cloud
computing is essential in today's
digital era to pave your way to become a
successful Cloud expert so what are you
waiting for enroll in the course as
mentioned in the description and take
your career to the next level thank you
for joining us and we hope you found
this video informative thank you and
happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here